a century of history flashes before your
eyes
not the past but
the future
and now you know how life would unfold
over the next 100 years
what changes would happen to the planet
over that time
what countries would become world
leaders
and
why would you not want to live in
california
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you knew what would happen
over the next 100 years
there are so many things that could
happen over 100 years
the population of the planet could
continue to grow
technologies would change
diseases would be eradicated
and the human impacts of climate change
could worsen
but
no one can see the future
except for you of course and
you're about to witness it all
[Music]
you can witness the future of video
games with mech arena in case you've
been living under a rock for the last
couple of months mac arena is a brand
new tactical team-based five-on-five
shooter yeah introducing mech arena it
has the most formidable mechs and
weapons to fight with hundreds of
amazing skins to customize your mechs
and an array of cool arenas to battle in
believe me the crazy battles and events
will get you hooked immediately want to
test your skills against me
look for rabid beaver and try to stop me
as i lay waste in the redox mech the
caustic blast will get you every time
get your squad together for crazy 5 on 5
matches or go one on one in maps that
force you to consider every decision in
deadly games of cat and mouse sign up
and take advantage of mech arena's new
battle pass which gives you the ability
to win new prizes in competitive events
click on the link in the description
below and download mec arena on your
android or ios device and get 500 acorns
70 000 credits and the exclusive steel
reaper skin to boost your mech to the
next level maybe you'll last a few
rounds against me
maybe
2025.
by the year
2025 you'd see how india surpassed china
and became the most populated country in
the world
its population would grow to over 1.44
billion people
you'd also see some of the continued
effects of global warming
yeah the arctic would become ice free
for several months of the year
between july and november
polar bears would struggle to live on
the disappearing ice sheets
and while the earth would undergo these
dramatic changes we'd also lose contact
with the voyager 1 reporting back from
space
this deep space probe has been carrying
a gold-plated disc containing sounds and
images from earth since its launch in
1977
2037
by the year 2030 you'd get a small dose
of positive news
the battle against malaria would be
close to victory
in 2017 there were around 216
million cases of the disease but
the widespread use of mosquito nets
treated with insecticides would almost
eliminate it
but things would get seriously shaken up
in california
a major earthquake would hit along the
roughly 1300 kilometer long san andreas
fault
the damage would be enormous with
thousands of deaths and injuries
as well as billions of dollars in losses
2050
jumping ahead to the year 2050
you'd find that robots have taken over
many jobs
yeah they'd be running the hospitals
transportation and security
your wages would go down and traditional
manufacturing jobs would likely be
non-existent
on the bright side based on current
research
you could see a universal basic income
implemented in many parts of the world
hopefully you'd also see a complete
transition of energy resources from
fossil fuels to carbon neutral ones
wind or solar power could be providing
nearly all of the world's
electricity 2060
despite all efforts to move to green and
renewable energy
global warming wouldn't go anywhere and
by the year 2060 global temperatures
would have increased by over 3 degrees
if you lived along the coastline you'd
see your home devastated by rising sea
levels and intense storms
new york city would likely build massive
sea walls to protect from frequent mass
flooding
and that would cost hundreds of billions
of dollars
2068
fast forwarding a few years to 2060
you would see humans get faster thanks
to optimized workouts innovative
technological implants and muscle
enhancing devices
you'd witness an impossible world record
set in the 100 meter sprint
at this point people could become bionic
your body could carry all kinds of nano
technologies that monitor health or do
fun things like make your skin glow with
different patterns or colors
[Music]
2090
by the 2090s
humans would get creative about
ingesting their proteins
there'd be no more consumption of
traditional meats like beef or pork
they'd be out of fashion due to their
enormous carbon footprint
that right now accounts for
14.5 percent of the world's greenhouse
gases instead you'd be eating fully
lab-grown or plant-based meat
[Music]
but livestock industries wouldn't be the
only thing facing extinction
many languages would disappear by the
year 2090.
english and mandarin would likely
compete as the two most dominant
languages spoken everywhere on the
planet
2100
at the dawn of the next century
you could witness technology that would
allow us to control extreme seismic
events like earthquakes and tsunamis
we'd have an incredible knowledge of
what's going on below the surface and
could accurately predict where and when
these events would occur
21 21
finally at the end of your journey
through the future
in the year
2121
you'd reach the point where you could
upload your mind to a computer
yeah congratulations you've reached
immortality
now
get back to the present and help make
some of those good things happen
after all if you could see the future
could you change it
well
you already know what i'm about to say
that's a story
for another
what if